I will say I am I was a little dishonest
about something Hannah Brown reveals
just how many times she had sex with
Peter Webber in that windmill and
struggles with her family and the final
two men
[Music]
for tomorrow and
during at night one of the dramatic
two-part season finale of The
Bachelorette Hana dropped this bombshell
no I did say there's something that
Peter and I did twice it was actually
four times while his parents were in the
audience clapping
[Applause]
we saw Hannah in tears over saying
goodbye to Peter and he was watching
live in studio with Chris Harrison where
he was still visibly upset you okay yeah
I was kind of dreading having to wash
that back this entire time friend less
just two months and admits he's still
getting over Hannah I don't think you
can completely fall out of love with
someone and it's been two months
although we never got answers on Peters
alleged ex-girlfriend drama his mom
seemingly hinted at it I know how he
felt and it hasn't been easy
well my heart gets broken a lot for a
lot of different reasons later we see
Hannah's remaining men Jed Wyatt and
Tyler Cameron meet the Brown family
Hannah admits she's falling in love and
so was her family I know that I've been
falling in love with you I've been
excited to tell you that would mean the
world to me
I'm so
oh my gosh the Tyler has a piece of my
heart in my I don't know I'm just so
excited but when it comes to Jed well he
faced some difficulty with the former
pageant princesses BAM Hannah's father
clearly had reservations about the 25
year old musician dying ones
accomplishments were up to this point
and he was very proud of the dog food
jingle Diddy didn't that's not what
that's what he said he was you know
proud about which sent Hannah into a
tailspin over both men just thinking
about and Jed so many feelings are in
each relationship I know that I'm loved
deeply I
I know that I'll break
[Music]
we'll have to wait until Tuesday to see
part two of the finale will Hanna get
engaged the past couple of months have
been really tough and emotional I know
there are a lot of rumors out there and
honestly tomorrow night I don't know
what's gonna happen but I have a lot of
questions that need to be answered so I
hope I'll be able to do that you told me
in our very first interview that you
didn't want to end up with a lying sack
of poo does that happen well we don't
know who I end up with yet and we will
have to continue to watch oh we will and
hopefully we'll find out about those
pesky rumors surrounding Jed's
ex-girlfriend
when et spoke with Chris Harrison he
assured fans they will get answers
what's the number one question you want
to ask Jen it's not I guess it's not as
much of a question I want his
perspective I want his say you know
there's there's always three sides to
the truth you know their version their
version and then the real version